hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand line waifu
and today i'm hoping there's enough to
discuss about episode 141 and 142
because
episode 141 was an odd combination of
some intriguing things being dampened
and somewhat mismanaged by the inclusion
of other things
and the most interesting thing that's
happened so far is the return of leorio
and i'm really glad that is the case
because i'm glad he's having an impact
on a world that frankly he didn't have
much of an impact on before which is
really important i say that
he's had some great moments in the show
so far and i'm glad we got backstory
from him and that he was present for
some of those things but i feel as
though
to now he's been largely underutilized
i'm hoping that now
as he becomes important to more
characters he will become more integral
to the story because he deserves it he
deserves it
you're a good guy if anything i would
have preferred it if you'd been integral
to a different arc because i'm still
struggling so much to connect with this
one and my reasons for that are
several fold let's go the first is the
voting situation which doesn't feel real
or important to me and i'm
not clear why it matters on a broader
scale i get that it's important that
gone's friends see how much of a dick
his dad is
and believe that he doesn't care about
his son but i'm struggling with the
concept that there's more to the voting
which is
odd because i know that there has to be
more after all this time i trust that
takashi must have some larger concept or
larger idea in mind he wouldn't bring
those two things together
in this arc if there weren't something
important to happen
the problem is i'm missing it and i
don't want to be when gone is wished
better and if that all works maybe we're
going to have to get all the hunters
together to deal with the fallout of the
wish
or maybe we're going to have to deal
with the missing hunters because we have
another of takashi's famous threads to
consider or maybe something else is
going to happen
but it hasn't happened yet i hope we get
to the inciting incident soon though
because i'm scared we've already hit it
in both threads of this dna strand arc
which is similar to
the killa mountain home arc i guess and
i don't want that to be the case without
my interest
really engaged the second thing i'm
struggling with is the way the other
strand keewa's arc with alaka
and his family feels like it should be
fascinating
i feel like i should be at the edge of
my seat but i must be missing something
and
it's difficult because my mind keeps
sticking on the fact that for no
narrative reason at all
kilwa re-explained everything that has
happened in this arc to now we haven't
had enough episodes in the arc to really
get to a point where we need a recap of
everything but we got one anyway
whenever kilwa is shown doing this i get
the distinct
flavor of stretch to the episode as in
they needed
an extra five minutes of content and
this was the best way to do it without
adding obvious filler and while it also
fits with who kilwa
is in the first arc when he did things
like this there was new information to
be had
or new things he'd seen or experienced
or some new insight
and so it was forgivable but with this
kind of watching i get bored because not
only am i learning nothing new but he's
not sharing anything new
from himself from the character the
order's even roughly the same and then
it just holds up the new information in
the scene
which in this case was illumi saying
time to die bruh
and the problem with trying to build
tension this way is that there's a
difference between stillness because
tension and stillness becomes boredom
one of them is actively disengaging
while the other suspends us and i'm sad
because i didn't feel suspended and it
would have been such a powerful moment
if i were truly taken by surprise
at the truck trying to slam into them
because it was a cool moment it visually
looked appealing i
wanted that i loved that that happened
but i felt like it was undercut by the
fact that we spent five minutes just
going back on things that we didn't need
to
i'll be honest there's a lot of
fuzziness in the storyline that i'm not
really understanding and in an arc that
i'm not inclined to enjoy simply because
of what we've come
out of i'm finding myself somewhat
miffed that i feel after this time
back to square one because we're
learning the culture of one very obscure
and strange family we knew nothing about
before and as much as getting into the
world
of ants which i'll admit was bizarre
was a hard pill to swallow this isn't
just a hard pill to swallow but
one that is labor intensive because
we're learning the politics and the
culture of this family
while learning the politics and culture
of the hunter association and it feels
sort of out of context you know his key
and illumi's relationship is sort of
saving the situation for me
despite everything else happening illumi
seems to be trying to kill one of his
siblings without killing
another of them i love that hisoka's got
a double agent situation happening and
i find it curious that illumi hasn't
seen it or its expression with these
kids before
especially since hisoka has not hidden
that behavior
like not ever i know they've been busy
doing different things and i'm surprised
someone is single-mindedly as illumi
could have missed hisoka's relationship
to the protagonists
that said single-mindedness could be the
reason for it too
i guess so maybe not why there is such
in-house fighting i'm not sure but the
idea that illumi doesn't see aluka's
family
or is using a technicality to change
that fact tells me a lot about how
illumi sees the world or how
illumi's trying to manipulate the world
or how
illumi is just deciding how he's gonna
be
how he's gonna get around things i don't
really know even more so
since he directly asked kilowatt whether
the needle had been taken from his head
so
trying to protect one sibling while the
other is specifically the target takes
finesse and
care and not let's just hurl some
exploding trucks at him i guess
who who tell me who is hiring them as
assassins because they're
so messy and at the end of the day i
wonder how well-adjusted the regular
citizens of this world are to the
concept of death
after all if an assassin doesn't get
them an ant will
and if an ant doesn't an exploding
beautiful fiery rose does and it just
doesn't seem safe to be a normal person
in this world at all but that's okay
because we're not watching a world of
normal people we're watching a world
where a guy with a few coins can make
them move as fast as bullets
i do not believe that goto has much of a
chance but hey let's see
either way it was nice knowing him
though i haven't really had an opinion
on him this arc so i guess it wasn't
nice knowing him one of the threads i
am interested in is how intensely kilwa
cares about alaka is that another needle
in his head or someone else's wish
cause it's big emotion maybe i'll
finally learn what killer is if not a
human
episode 142 and finally finally i have a
reason to care about this arc as kiwa
gets the hunters involved to hunt his
brother
and end the situation as i complained
about the ark to my husband he pointed
out that i love kilauea and seem to hate
his family i'm here to say it's not all
true
i don't hate his family i hate that they
seem to be used as a soul for no clear
reason
and i have yet to see them actually
complete a task that
involves assassination i mean are they
assassins or are they killers and
and dragon bus drivers like i don't i
mean there was a there was one moment
where
someone was assassinated in
a number of arcs ago illumi did it good
job illumi you
can be an assassin i think i feel like
we've seen a number of people more
powerful than them and a number of
people who seem more capable of
assassinating a single person rather
than everyone i mean
assassination could be a whole group of
people but i mean i guess
illumi isn't being paid to kill one
person this is a labor of love but i'm
still less impressed than i be
for i don't know an actual assassin
family you know i want to be i want to i
want to see the cool
i want to see them being like sneaky and
cool they this is not a sneaky family
and i feel like we've been given this
huge amount of information about them
and their home and it just hasn't been
used instead we find out more about the
family just cause
and they all really should have
considered that kilauea would do
something stupid
and family focused rather than stupid
and family protective because
he's clearly not like them and never has
been and he clearly doesn't like them
all that to say i dislike his family but
i guess the dynamics are naturalistic
enough that i can go
if i got mad enough at my sister i'd
probably call a global hunting
organization to hunt her down and force
her to return the cakes she stole from
the fridge when she was eight too
the idea that kilwa cares more about
alaka than he does about illumi makes
total sense to me and i
like that he's going through with it
what i do wonder is whether it's going
to work
if i'm honest i don't really understand
the politics within the hunter
organization at this point in time it
seems they want to make changes to a
charter we neither knew existed nor have
seen all of and if i'm honest i don't
really want to know all of it because
that's another one of those
encyclopedic things that happen the fact
that there are hunter rules at all
is entirely news to me and i can't help
but think that maybe this should have
been foreshadowed in
i don't know the first arc where i spent
the entire time asking what a hunter
even was
and i'm still not sure what a hunter is
beyond someone who puts their attention
into finding things but that's vague
given the range of things it's possible
to choose to find and it annoys me
because i like specificity i want i want
to read that charter please
what wasn't vague was that scene of
hisoka killing goto i enjoyed that fight
it was smart it was well animated a good
length and i enjoyed the movement of it
i loved that it flowed from beginning to
end and i enjoyed the level of tension
and attention given to something that
really only deserved the amount of
attention it got
meanwhile killer still running from his
trunchbull who's a freaking motorcycle
i don't think i can get behind the idea
of someone becoming a nen motorbike and
i struggle even more with the idea of
someone's granddaughter riding them on
said bike i just don't fire
i'm so confused by subuni's array of
abilities that i kind of just wonder how
she's keeping distance right now
especially since we know she has to be
somewhere near the two kids at the
moment is the motorbike capable of
hovering is this like a magical harry
potter bike
i do have to say that i'm enjoying this
development of hisoka as a comedic
rather than
dramatic element of this art he's a very
flexible character but i find it
intriguing that after everything we've
been through
hisoka returning means we can't see him
seriously anymore he's not as dark as
the last arc was no
but i feel as though the darkness he
provided in the earlier arcs and his own
goals have been shunted to the side so
that the present arc has someone to
explain things to
and laugh at or laugh with and i'm i'm i
have mixed feelings on this
narrative shift for hisoka but at the
same time i like it i do miss a tissue
driven to achieve his own
ends which feels sort of minimal here
and part of the problem is that it's
just leading to him being a sidekick
with social anxiety i love my hiskey
please don't break
and with my hiskey firmly protected
that's it from me
if you enjoyed the turmoil i'm feeling
about this whole arc click here here
and here and i'll see you next time